it's like no pandemics happening
one state is taking things a certain way
another state is taking things another
way
and why are the results not that much
different this has been like a massage
for my brain
if you shut down mom and pop's
operations down here
might as well pick up and leave word too
though used to be a nice
place oh it's not good to be free to be
there on the street
you know nothing like though it's
wonderful look i think people are
really suffering mentally those are some
aggressive shades i like them
just escaped north korea aka california
under the enlightened leadership of kim
jong-un
and it's unbelievable guys it's
unbelievable that these two states
exist in the same country so this video
is going to enlighten some of you put a
smile on your face
and for others it might make you a bit
mad
[Music]
but what i want you to see here is the
feel i've been getting
is it's like 2019 versus 2021.
going with an open mind and
let this story unravel we're going to
get on these streets
i'm going to show you what i'm talking
about i'm going to try to get that vibe
across to you
talk to some people and learn something
along the way
let's do it
[Music]
one thing i've felt the uh
the week i've been here is just the
energy
is is like no pandemics happening
doesn't mean people aren't wearing masks
a lot are on the streets but there's
just
uh i don't feel that fear the anxiety
the the mistrust of everyone the lack of
eye contact none of that going on
i'm doubting there are too many locals
here
it's mostly firstly tourists
escaping everything i gotta
that's what i'm loving here is people
open friendly
having a good time that's what i have
not felt
for quite some time what's up brother
how are you doing
you chilling what's this what's the
story what's the story miami beach good
out here man i love it i'm from
mississippi
your uh boyfriend or husband whatever he
is funny guy funny guy
i'm a husband
all right we're having a good time out
here
[Music]
okay what was going on in kentucky
you're from kentucky right yeah yeah
man they was trying to sue our governor
man because he tried mandate masks and
they got mad at the man
[ __ ] kentucky man they got mad at
the man
they still on so you're saying
kentucky's more open than here
yeah yeah that's almost hard to believe
you got beat out to see it man i mean
they actually
upset that you tell them to put their
mask on man inside
yeah you could be in the grocery store
kroger's anything man they're gonna do
mad you tell them put a mask on you're
gonna
ran into some confrontations yes all
right
it's pretty wild over man i thought this
was the most open place in the country
to be honest
kentucky's next level yeah yeah it's a
little different people are upset they
got put on the mass man it's crazy
people got parents out here let me take
care of something yeah
yeah i mean it's the old people that are
getting hammered
most mostly
what up guys you from miami where you
guys from
richmond virginia how's it feel with the
covet and everything
freedom freedom life life man here you
got to go back everything
buttoned up yeah everybody walking
around scared
like you said fresh air then yeah life
is back yeah yeah
we look we're looking at each other
exactly human beings good to see you yes
and so here's something i would like to
get into uh
look this isn't a video about what you
should do with masks
if you should go outside or not it's
just a video to show what it's like
in one part of the country i've been
doing stuff in san francisco and i'm
here so complete opposites
the thing is i would love to see a
journalist go into the story of
numbers here per hundred thousand so per
capita deaths
very similar to california florida is
number two
as far as senior citizens per capita
california
it's either 45th or 46
as far as senior citizen meaning over
65.
so who's getting it the worst with the
covet is over 65 it's very clear in the
data if you look at it
i highly suggest looking at it so over
65 that's the real at-risk group
obviously people that have pre-existing
conditions and other health issues
that's a high risk too
so the old people are here things are
open
we're gonna walk by some restaurants
we're gonna go into some other parts of
the city
but you can you can get a feel here now
to be fair this is the tourist part so i
think it's gonna be a little more
a little more open people a little more
relaxed
but why why are the rates
uh death pretty per 100 000 uh very
similar and what i would love to see i
think we would all love to see
is not a political you know
republican democrat story here just uh
objective journalists going in going in
deep on the numbers of both states
so is it because it's more humid here
is that a reason that that that covet
isn't
you know 10x worse than california
because everyone's
out and about things are not closed down
things are open
life is happening or what is the reason
i don't know
i would love to know unfortunately we
don't have
that time of type of mainstream
journalism these days
maybe any of you guys have seen this
story comparing california
in florida and the different strategies
and the different results
please please leave that for all of us
down below
in the description got people out and
about enjoying
hello waitresses
service people have masks
everyone sitting down doesn't from
california bro
so how's it feel to be here in in miami
coming from california we love it man
it's
not locked down out here it's like the
whole world it's like a different world
honestly
it's like 2019 isn't it yeah yeah
here we have the breakwater classic art
deco
looks like the front of a 50s car
something like that just art deco all
down this drive here what is this street
the collins i forget the name excellent
people watching
all sorts all types that's what's great
about miami it's properly mixed up
every latin community in volumes here
pretty much every ethnicity not
not as many asians i gotta say is the
west
from what i've seen but it's a proper
mix it's a proper collection infusion of
people from all over as you can see
here we have versace's house he was
murdered
on the front steps here that's how he
went out
so miami beach was very much a party
place well it has all these different
phases so
it was it was run by the mob back in the
day then world war ii came
and actually all of these hotels cleared
out
for servicemen who were training for
world war ii
afterwards it fell into decline
then it came back it became the
playground for the rich
the rich and famous coming down from new
york city coming down from the east
coast
in the winters escaping the snow and the
cold sort of like right now
fell into decline again uh miami
what's the show miami vice miami vice
was filmed here
so a lot of these art deco buildings
were
empty falling apart
and miami vice actually the show they
painted and set things back
in order
[Music]
what's up you're twerking you're
twerking
[Music]
let's see it happy birthday
twerking
[Applause]
i just learned about twerking that's how
out of pop culture i am
the girl was turking twerking on the
elevator when it opened the other day
and it was a serious twerk i mean
if you could harness the power of that
twerk that i saw would have
you know powered the whole hotel and
probably the city so there you go
love it or hate it that's miami style
hey guys what was i saying okay with the
history
so miami vice came through here brought
back a lot of these
properties and made it world famous
and then afterwards people a lot of
people europeans came in a lot of
russians came in
uh wanting wanting a little piece of the
beach in the warmth
i think you're from brazil yeah i'm from
brazil what do you think of miami
i love miami i always did that was
always real i think
how does it feel here right now compared
to brazil oh it's so good to be free to
be
on the street you know nothing like
though it's wonderful
i love it i love it and you're not
scared no i'm not scared at all
because you're healthy i'm healthy not
just that when you
the day won't come that you're gonna die
you're gonna die doesn't matter what
yeah okay so that's what i believe
and you're not stressed out i'm not
assess out i'm not scared
no i'm not i'm happy good for you have
fun
you too bye-bye okay you can see the
authorities are making an attempt
that's not it's not going over so well
as you can see
and i just want to be very clear because
i'm showing this
doesn't mean i don't believe in covet or
denying it it's it's very much a real
thing
and i've had many friends and i know of
many people who have had it
most have gone through to the other side
without much of a problem
i've heard of some older people
through a direct connection that have
died
those who have pre-existing conditions
you know have other complications covet
hits them much harder
and then there are the outliers of the
people that you know are 15 years old
and die from the disease it's not a it's
not a video about denying it
it's a video about asking questions of
you know
one state is taking things a certain way
that another state is taking things
another way
and why are the results not that much
different
that's what i would love to know because
the mental consequences
of the policies of the lockdowns in
california are heavy
and you really can't you really don't
know it it's like the frog in the
in the boiling pot you really don't feel
it if you're in it but when you get out
of it
all right whoa that was that was not
a good thing i was in and so here
people are out of the pot they're going
about their life i've talked to all
sorts of people here and some are more
fearful than others but what you don't
feel is this
judgment you don't get the bad looks
or the no looks it feels quite
normal and i really hope there's some
behavioral scientists observing what's
going on
in different parts of the country right
now and documenting all of
the different strategies and what the
different results lead to as far as
people's psychology
honestly it feels like my blood pressure
has gone down
quite a bit anxiety has gone down stress
has gone down
where i live in san francisco there's a
there's a hiking trail system and
there everyone's wearing a mask outside
and if i'm close to someone outside i'll
wear a mask
and even with that going on the trail in
nature
what's up you guys hey buddy how's life
it's man it's great because i'm here i
know i
hear it how good is this it's amazing
fantastic where uh where are you guys
from
uh minnesota we're from the pale north
you can't tell where are you from
those shade that's those are some
aggressive shades i like them
burned in my memory because my wife and
i to get some sanity back
and i make videos what are you making a
video are we on your video right yeah
you are
all right it's his fault youtube
what's your youtube channel how did she
get so bronzed up and you're still going
it's called
it's called this magical spread oh you
sprayed up okay gotcha
gotcha that's a big big isn't this
beautiful like being out in person and
being with people and talking with
people and not being on a screen
those glasses man you're ready to like
take over a small country with us
i like them see you guys okay back to
what i was saying the
trail in san francisco in nature
like even with the mask up even with
distance there's all this tension
no eye contact none of that
right that does not exist and
here you have one of those 20-somethings
off the screens hanging out talking with
each other enjoying life
and you realize how important that is
like we're definitely not meant to be
looking at screens and
scare being scared of each other you
know the eye contact thing
the energy that can be felt of like
wanting to connect with people it's
so important it's very important just
these moments
getting a coconut with your daughter
[Music]
that's pleasure that's that's what was
before
a very simple pleasure but now is
i considered the most important pleasure
in life it's just basic moments like
that
where are you from san francisco used to
be a nice
place years ago you were there a lot
yeah my wife and i are going to have to
move and like
yeah my wife and i are going to have to
live in like a half here continues on
it's just
it sucks it's not fun to live no my idea
how many friends
i have that have left california in the
last
actually a year in the last year
i mean people that have lived there most
of their adult lives
successful in business and they just say
it's not worth it
i mean not only just the taxes but just
you know the standard of living and
you're afraid to go out on the street
it's just not the same you know we have
distance that's we're outside there's a
breeze going
through the risk is very low
and i don't feel the fear and that to me
is like
is actually everything in life no matter
how beautiful place is
if the human energy is so off
it's not it's not you're not comfortable
you're afraid to go out of your house
are you gonna drive your car being
outside doesn't bother me if i go
in a building in a restaurant yeah i put
my mask on yeah
i got you you guys all buddies from d.c
that's right
how's miami so far oh it's beautiful
exactly what i wanted to yeah let's hit
the beach
i just saw my first twerking experience
and
right in front of me i'm 43 and married
i've been out of the country for a while
and i never had a twerk happening
yeah there you go this lady's twerk
in the elevator if you could harness the
energy it would have powered the hotel
that is true
[Music]
just like that beach restaurant hotel
out to the street so now we're gonna go
into downtown miami check out that scene
that stuff really used to annoy me
though super loud music ah that wasn't
that bad but there's some cars that are
really pumping it and then the harleys
you know you can't hear yourself think
but in these times it's lovely
it shows people expressing themselves it
shows life
it's your barber shop man yes sir did
you guys have to close it off
uh only one they required us to so look
back last year right
yeah for like three months about three
to three months yeah can we go in
yeah all right your business
that's it oh very cool family business
cool
wow i would i can't give you any
business man uh that's fine but uh
business has been pretty good
you know with everything that's going on
we can't really complain you know
the bills and stuff you know that's
great it's sort of like a men's club in
here huh yes sir
right now going on in here what's your
name my name is justin peter
all right take care have a good one
[Music]
you don't want to take care of yourself
what's drew
that's justin bieber's brent uh i'm
still out of pop culture huh dude
i know
love the business stories i love to see
the businesses that are surviving
so guys you can see all these cruise
ships at port
so obviously not functioning this
industry has been absolutely
crushed and so outside my hotel about a
mile
off the coast it was a cruise ship just
sort of doing circles
all night long all day long and what i
was told is there's a skeleton crew out
there
that's you know just basically
maintaining these ships and there's
there's so many there's so many ships
that there's a lack of port space so
they actually have to rotate they
put a ship out to see circles around for
a couple days
then it goes back to port and then they
switch up
[Applause]
[Music]
love projam radio the driving here
i'm gonna put on par with riyadh saudi
arabia those two
are in competition for the worst driving
i've seen in the world
i think it's because you put you you
slam together so many people from
different countries
that all have different driving rules
and you put them on the same roads
then you get this we got an accident up
here that's why we're in traffic
[Music]
here in brickell the center of miami
it's quite beautiful actually it's
much nicer than i thought it would be
from what i've seen clean
streets a lot of modern architecture
a lot of new apartment buildings it
feels
thriving here it feels alive it feels
like things are building
building up the energy's on the up
not on the down who knows if i'm right
on that but that's what it feels like at
least
miami seems to be all about the cars
and they actually become quite normal
to see things like lamborghinis and
maseratis
nice benzes
so i think you get the feel guys
different different feel than miami
beach
now we're gonna go to wynwood which is
the artistic district
i've been told it's quite cool a lot of
little eclectic restaurants
such a great feel this neighborhood
windwood so restaurants over there
new apartment check this out auto body
shop
right in the mix more restaurants
just a very nice chill vibe
in wynwood you're building a new million
dollar restaurant here yes
how's the restaurant seen these days
great you look you go around and you'll
see them they're all packed
it's friday night everybody's in a
restaurant saturday night everybody's
out here
so it's life is normal life is normal
and they
they couldn't close it that we're
miami's buddy we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna fight it
and your cove it's not any higher per
capita it's a little bit higher per
capita than california
very small amount there was well we got
a lot of retirees
yeah got a lot of old people here but
you're open but we're open
every bit if you shut down mom and pops
operations down here
might as well pick up and leave word too
though
texas yeah so we just gotta struggle and
we just gotta keep
safe and common sense like the governor
says yeah that's it
the mayor here in miami is excellent the
the they counting the new man that we
got she's you know she's
democrat but she's okay you know so far
she hasn't closed anybody
or done any craziness you know with the
whole thing
so people are pretty pretty optimistic
here overall in miami
yes that's what i felt i felt like well
you got on these streets it's life and
things are building and
you're building a restaurant we're
closing them down you're building them
yes we are there's a lot of new yorkers
coming down
now from from new york down here
hopefully restaurants
it's amazing what we have on work you're
proud to be from florida
oh oh yeah well the real florida boys
this is more of a eclectic maybe hipster
i don't even know if that's the word
these days
uh small business artistic type place
and that guy back there ray i think
that's what his name was ray he's a very
proud floridian and uh
after i turned the camera off he started
going into the details about like
how this state has benefited his small
business how
things are thriving well i don't need to
tell you you can hear and see
from all over they come here to paint
yeah oh that's cool
tony goldberg tony goldberg goldman
okay thank you yeah we have an app if
you want to download it
as well okay thank you
so this used to be a really bad
neighborhood
the woman was saying 10 years ago this
guy tony goldman
came in and started these
these art installations artists from all
over the world
and it's just a nice little place to
walk around
outside and you can see you can see
outside on the streets how
busy it is and lively cool young vibe
here
[Music]
it's back to the original question is
miami normal
in these times and i'd say it's the most
normal place
that i've been during covid and i think
there's something to learn from this
i would love it if we could be in a
world where mainstream media would be
interested
to say hey this isn't a political thing
this is demographic republican whatever
it's not that it's about
why if florida is completely open and
california's mostly closed
are the coveted rates virtually the same
per capita
and especially since florida has a much
older population it's number two in the
country for over 65 california i think
is number 45 out of 50 states for over
65.
maybe it's the humidity maybe it's a
whole host of other factors
but it wouldn't be nice to know right
because i'll tell you what this has been
like a massage
for my brain and it's it's made me feel
human again it's
it's gotten so out of whack in san
francisco look i think people are really
suffering
mentally and i don't feel that suffering
here i mean just look at this
my wife and i even extended our time
another week
just to store up these feelings before
we go back
to the land of kim jong-nusum
and the lockdowns so i hope you got
something out of that
i'm not telling you what to think about
covid you look at the data that's all at
look at the data and come up with your
own conclusions
this is just what it looks like here a
completely different world
then it's unbelievable another state in
this country this country is
so diverse so mixed up and even when it
comes to covet there can be different
completely different realities oh
so i'm going to be going uh going into
different neighborhoods i got some
videos coming gonna be going into the
venezuelan neighborhood here the cuban
neighborhood here
the brazilian neighborhood the russian
ukrainian
i got another one i'll keep on secret
because it's uh i'm still working on i
don't know if i can nail it down
but all sorts of content coming from
miami thanks for coming along oh if you
want to
support my page i got a patreon down
below
until the next one see ya